un bon jour dans la française bonjour
quel ques bon un novice à l'argentin
[Musique]
alors autour de la table qui sont ils
ces mécréants qui vont nous accompagner
durant cette émission spéciale su
comment ce gain la fête nationale des
québécois une fête internationale c'est
notre thème
alors il ya d'abord oui oui de la
section jeunesse de radio canada
international à marivan de la section
espace autochtones oui ya marie claire
simard qui est avec nous je savais que
j'avais eu un peu de lumière à cenon la
ritorte bonjour bonjour
et puis les eaux gimeno qui contrôle
tout alors ces deux là c'est des
webmestres et ces trois là ce sont des
annonceurs réalisateur voilà pour vous
décrire un peu cette réalité où on
mélange tout le monde ensemble pas
encore plus de plaisir on est plus on a
plus de plaisir maintenant oui
avant ça dans des émissions de radio est
un peu vieillot notre histoire tout le
reste est vieillot devant un micro pas
de caméras pour dire bonjour
c'était une autre époque simplement
maintenant les choses ont changé mais je
voulais d'abord va voir cette semaine
c'était le solstice posent leurs marques
et faisait clair beaucoup de plumes
faisait clair et c'était une fait pour
par seulement des québécois qui sait le
24 heures jeudi si les autochtones et
pour eux c'est important de faire la
distinction n'est ce pas entre le 24
juin le 1er juillet et le 21 juin qui
est la journée nationale des autochtones
que justin trudeau le premier ministre
du canada a rebaptisé à partir de l'an
prochain la journée nationale des
peuples autochtones
mais c'est bien c'est quoi la différence
j'ai pas le bassin dit j'ai surtout
surtout la difficulté de la traduit en
chinois parce qu'un chinois
c'est la même chose je ne sais pas
comment la distance et en chinois les
deux versions oui mais c'est tout ce
peuple autochtone ah bon l'e2c l'aviez
déjà la version parce qu'on est obligés
d'ajouter le peuple sinon ça marche pas
parce que chez les autochtones
ben en fait il ya trois peuples il ya
les premières nations il ya les inuits
et les métis
alors ça s'appelle comment
officiellement maintenant journée
nationale des peuples autochtones
naissance donc à partir de ce qu'on en
fait à partir de l'an prochain puisque
justin trudeau l'a annoncé le 21 juin
journée nationale des autochtones
jusqu'à présent 21e journée nations en
angola il ya plus de différence s'il
semble ces autochtones et un dj en fait
on les appelle oui les indians ce qui
veut dire autochtone tout simplement et
qui inclut donc les premières nations
les inuits et les métis fabien ceci nous
mène au premier jeu questionnaire de la
semaine êtes vous prêts oui ça a été
très bien en votre absence n'arrive au
delta
[Rires]
c'était pas mal ex-aequo leurs affaires
il ya trois jeux par émission donc une
chance j'ai pas une chance ou moins une
chance sur trois d'avoir une fois de
bonne foi la bonne réponse donc c'est un
concours pour voir lequel d'entre vous
est il plus proche des bonnes réponses
ok qu'est ce qui se passe en 1977 au
sujet de la fête nationale des québécois
qu'est ce qui se passe au québec en 1977
au sujet de la fête nationale des
québécois
on va commencer par un cas pas parlé du
tout léo 1 67 77
c'est pas la france de mon cher monsieur
palix au parisien le ministre québec
plus tard il a dit on a perdu le
référendum en raison des ethnies je
pense que non 1977 et depuis un an le
parti québécois le parti indépendantiste
du parti québécois est au pouvoir et il
le fait quelque chose de très spécial
comme justin trudeau le faire il ya
quelques jours sogerma bataille a dit
voilà on va fêter les vingt quatre ça va
être la fête nationale ça devient oui
c'est sorte à la saint-jean-baptiste ce
samedi officiellement la fête nationale
du québec
avant c'était la fête des canadiens
français 1 et c'est toujours la famille
mais c'était plus générale disons là il
a vraiment réorienter le tir
c'est une orientation disons politique
oui on aime ça quand même se faire
flageoler dans nos drapeaux
écoutez j'ai une autre question pour
vous et c'est la bonne question je sais
la question tu aimes écoutes de cette
semaine marie-claude nous dévoile la
grande affaire écoutez bien alors la
question cette semaine
d'abord on commence avec une petite
introduction à l'instar de tous les
francophones d'amérique que les
québécois célèbre la saint jean baptiste
ce 24 juin donc leur fête nationale quel
est donc leur plus belle réalisation ou
contribution d'hier aujourd'hui
marie-claude quelle est donc cette plus
grande que corps et du sang du québécois
puissent composer des dents on s'entend
que c'est une question là on y tombe à
l'école à veut pas punir les airs en
veulent et au moins une semaine 24
heures par jour
les autres qualités québec bell les
réalisations des francophones c'est donc
comment dire la plupart non mais
on va célébrer le 150ème du canada au
mois de juillet est en fait en fait
dernièrement le 375e de montréal qui a
été fondée par francophone français
c'est-à-dire francophones sont internes
quand même qui est assez moderne non pas
en fait on pas des français donc parlons
simplement de la réalisation de paul de
chomedey de maisonneuve qui a fondé
montréal avec la ville oui oui avec avec
jeanne mance entendu oui cofondatrice
matin ce dossier ça a été annoncé il ya
quelques uns ou deux il a été cimenté
pas sur une statue de plus le centre
ville quelque part mais en tout cas la
ferme et officielle alors répondons donc
à ces questions parce que claude yana je
commençais une bonne réponse mais elle a
mis la table à y assister
oui plus belle qualité des québécois
d'avoir préservé la langue française
c'est vrai oui il y a eu unanimité
autour d' attaque vrai ou faux vrai je
ne m'attendais pas à un coup alors
restons dans le contemporain aujourd'hui
en 2017
quelle est la plus belle qualité des
québécois mothern je pense que là on est
ouverts comme la société comme la
mentalité on est ouvert et on est je
suis je pense que pas seulement là vous
commandez ouvert au monde et moderne et
toujours avancer est-ce qu'on a des
images on n'a pas une vidéo qu'on devait
présenter
on n'a pas encore vu ça non là comment
comment les québécois célèbre la saint
jean baptiste
pendant qu'on voit ça on a coupé le son
parce qu'on joue de la musique et
connaissez le règlement c'est interdit
dommage mais j'en mets un peu love il ya
tellement de belles musiques et chansons
québécoises justement à faire découvrir
ce soir mais là on a préféré ne pas
jouer avec le feu et les politiques de
facebook
alors voici donc l'image on célèbre ça
sur la plaine dabra
am québec ça c'est une des plus belle
façon de célébrer moi j'allais célébrée
sur le mont royal à montréal argent
comme oral à québec
ah non mais attendez il ya eu des
célébrations incroyable au mont royal
des événements incontournables de
chanteurs québécois qui ont célébré sur
le mont royal
il ya les plaines d'abraham et a quand
même le mont royal et oui comment
célèbre chez vous la saint jean baptiste
à ce concept non pas c'est moi oui je
veux dire que ce bail à la maison pas
vraiment mais ce qui est impressionnant
je trouve pour cette fête c'est gai
tabac je pense que c'est une des seules
fait quand ils lisent entre les inconnus
ont dit pendant cinq ans quand on alors
est d'accord il ya un contact hervé
aaron type en cela et aussi dans tous
les quartiers et je pense que c'est le
seul prétexte de fêter le plus aimé le
plus préférés mais il faut le dire avec
l'accent parce que moi j'étais ajoutée
aux purs postière puis bon on dit
toujours merci parce qu'une fois qu'on a
rempli jeudi saint jean j ai un peu de
deux ans est devenu un peu et je vous
dis que ça a un effet les gens se
reconnaissent pas dans un sens il ya
quelque chose d'un petit courant qui
passe au niveau d'électricité pendant
d'électricité qui parlera passe pas
seulement par le québec elle paraît part
du québec des fois et puis elle se
ramassent à travers le pays en ontario
c'est là où on a présentement les plus
grandes fêtes de la saint jean baptiste
c'est pas des fêtes nationales là bas où
les plus élevés d'électricité non non je
pourrais vous en raconter des histoires
parce que je connais bien ce domaine là
émission spéciale à montner nature on
ferme la parenthèse on va en ontario il
ya anne marie pas marion marie-jo bain
marie vont il ya marie jobin qui a
demandé à marc andré gagnon de nous
parler des origines de cette fête pour
les franco ontariens
marc andré gagnon poursuit un doctorat
en uruguay en ontario sur les société
saint jean baptiste du québec et de la
francophonie canadienne ne beaucoup à
apprendre
voici un extrait gelé toute l'histoire
vous allez sur la page de tam-tam canada
c'est l'un de nos reportages en monde
cette semaine au niveau publicitaire en
fait d'un pub là et on donc une mine
presque 2 on écoute
[Musique]
à quand remontent les premières saint
jean baptiste
il faut à la suite de l'échec des
rébellion des patriotes et des
mouvements migratoires qui suit les
premières en 20 ans dans louis saint
jean d'âcre comme fête nationale
canadienne ou l'entendre parce que la
saint jean baptiste pour moi l'oublier
c'est une faille d'origine païenne qu'on
avait autorisés à 10 4 individus
importer en nouvelle france et anton
d'alain robbe cette photo pour en fait
une fête nationale un événement
patriotique la saison battu se répand à
travers les agathois re 10 15 des
français les différentes établissements
des parois en ontario parce que au début
du xxème
quand on maintenant de l'ontario et la
première crainte invenda quelques mois
je pouvais dans les insultes c'est à
toronto en évitant un camp de roux on a
une première mais pas dupe on comprend
qu'à l'époque la saison battu en fin
d'interview comme le nationaliste qu'un
des français d'ailleurs
alors une première messe à toronto 1852
où on fait un apport de qualité de la
famille canadienne française que l'on
voit ses pertes et à travers l'amérique
noire
alors voilà pour la suite bien sûr c'est
sur la page de tam-tam canada cette
semaine voici notre deuxième jeu
questionnaire
aujourd'hui deuxième jeu questionnaire à
l'émission et ça après on revient au
québec et je vous demande je peux pas je
peux pas te poser la question aux
québécois une québécoise c'est avoir la
réponse mais c'est pas la réponse avec
une honte nationale
alors marie-claude je vous la pose la
question voulez vous vraiment je vous la
pose
vas-y que vous êtes courageuse quelle
est donc la devise des québécois je me
souviens assister à son cours d'histoire
piqué ce qu ils se sourient de quoi se
souvient te voilà la question du lac
estion véritables questions du
questionnaire aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
ça veut dire je me souviens de merde
quoi
mais en fait ça va un peu dans la lignée
de ce que l'analyse est c'est que on va
se souvenir qu'on va garder nous
préserver notre langue
on va préserver nos traditions mais
patrick une autre culture cela mais
c'est un peu avec de la souffrance ne
jamais souviens c'était une comparaison
un peu stupide qui en fait avec les
l'immatriculation les plaques
d'immatriculation d amérique du nord aux
etats unis c'est le jeu pour
celle des golden state de l'autre c'est
la ville des orages l'autre c'est et où
l'amitié
je vais pas ici on se souvient sur la
plaque d'immatriculation
ça c'est au québec parce qu'en ontario
ou ailleurs c'est autre chose c'est sûr
mais c'est comme le lait le québécois
avec cette phrase là il ya comme une
abdication historique ici il ya le poids
de l'histoire est quelque chose quelque
chose qui se trament qu'est ce qui se
passe exactement dans la tête des
québécois oui il ya quelques années je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez
un de vos anciens collègues de jean
françois bolduc a fait un très bel
article là dessus
l'origine de je me souviens mais sauf
que je me suis fait beaucoup de mon fils
se souvient pas autour de la table mari
un retour dont on se souvient de quoi
exactement précisément là d'avoir été
battu sion des plaines d'abraham par les
anglais à une autre époque s'est passé
je vous dis je c'est possible je vais
vous donner un record je le dis parce
que je suis la seule personne qui a la
réponse au québec et non se souvient de
beaucoup de choses et ça peut être plein
de choses non mais à la vérité ces
personnes c'est pourquoi on se souvient
celui qui est l'auteur de la devise qui
a été le premier à l'écrire parce qu
écrire des choses de dire sur une chose
le chantait son affaire mais c'est bien
beau mais celui qui l'écrit c'est lui
qui est à l'origine c'était un
architecte qui est en train de créer
l'assemblée législative du québec
l'assemblée nationale l'actuel édifice
oui et il a oublié il n'a pas dit a
expliqué à personne pourquoi il avait
utilisé cette devise au haut d'une des
portes qui donnait accès jeudi explique
qu il ne l'a jamais expliqué mais ça
n'empêche pas les gens aujourd'hui les
eaux
on va le voir dans la vidéo de se perdre
en explications main voici donc une
entrevue qui a été réalisé pour répondre
à une question d'un auditeur on a parlé
avec brice dia ho ho cameron qui avait
justement cette question au bout des
lèvres mais pourquoi les québécois se
souvient-il
et de quoi
nantes est le québec et des curieux et
des look est de constater que la devise
du québec et je me souviens il m'a été
demandé pourquoi une telle de vie et
qu'elle est en pleine mutation
le fin fond d'histoire c'est sur le
parlement du québec donc l'assemblée
nationale c'est comme ça qu'on appelle
l'édifice du parlement québécois
c'est là où on a inscrit dans le béton
pratiquement dans la brique on l'a on la
sculpter sa dans la brique les premières
traces de ce type temps il y avait un
architecte à l'époque lorsqu'on à
construire ce parlement du québec qui
s'est dit je vais avoir des statuts de
plusieurs grands aventuriers ici au
canada au québec on va raconter
l'histoire sur la face sur le devant du
parlement l'histoire des québécois et à
travers cette histoire là je vais
inscrire trônant un petit peu parmi tous
ces personnages importants de l'histoire
je vais inscrire le dicton la devise je
me souviens je me souviens donc d
héritage britannique qui se trouvent
encore dans la culture des québécois
mais aussi des choses un peu plus
récente donc 1883 à ce moment là que les
plans du ce qu'on appellerait chez vous
le palais législatif du québec ont été
proposées et l'architecte en question
qui a eu l'idée d'inscrire ce devise du
québec sur la brique
c'était le jeune étienne taché alors
pour plusieurs je me souviens ça permet
de se souvenir de son histoire vous dis
pas relié marie-claude antenne de ceux
du devoir de la mémoire on se donne un
peu de voir l'un d'eux de toujours se
souvenir un peu de ce que nous en ferons
près
voici une autre question se pose une
question juste une question test pour
voir est-ce que vous pensez que les
québécois se raconte des histoires quand
il part de leur histoire est ce que vous
voulez dire c'est toujours comme ça
c'est pas seulement les québécois
oui je pense que c'est un devoir de
mémoire sélective un peu déjà prouvé un
premier ainsi à quelqu'un qui écrivent
l'histoire
ça veut dire qu'ils aiment notre
histoire nous étions par dieu qu'ils
n'ont pas et créé de l'est seront ok oui
ça c'est une chose
oui il autre chose c'est que quand on
bat c'est normal quand on essaie d d
enrichir l'histoire
alors on donne des détails qui n'étaient
pas là on ajoute des choses pour que
l'histoire soit belle un centre
ah bon alors sa cellule dans la personne
les cours d'histoire enrichissant un
geste humain très bien mais on les fait
avec nous même quand on a quelque chose
à jouer une expérience en argentine
c'est pas exactement comme je la raconte
j'ai ajouté des choses mais pas
nécessairement consciemment on les fait
pour que les récits ici
les historiens ne sont pas là pour
réajuster les choses quand même oui mais
attention attention là mais j'ai
fréquenté plusieurs institutions
scolaires différent de mes villes
françaises française québécoise
il peut vous dire que dépendamment de
kiel professeur d'histoire les choses
changent pas mal et puis en plus ici
particulièrement avec l'histoire de la
langue
si la langue la raconte c'est un fait il
si l'histoire se raconte et en anglais
je pense que c'est pas exactement la
même chose que quand on la compta
français et vous quand vous décrivez
oui l'histoire du québec aux gens qui
sont à l'étranger votre marché c'est
essentiellement le marché de la chine
est-ce que vous marcher sur des oeufs
vous pouvez dire des choses que les
québécois n'ont ce pas dire comment vous
présentez les choses parce que c'est un
peuple qui a été battu littéralement par
les anglais des anglais un essaim 80-69
cette salle
je pense quand on est il faut dire que
si on le raconte un peu comme hors du
jeu la troisième partie de la troisième
personne si vous voulez c'est à dire que
peut-être il ya un peu moins de moindre
émotion et moins de souvenirs
oui c'est oui oui c'est ça moins de
souvenirs je crois que c'est collectif
c'est ça fait une différence parce que
je me souviens il ya quelques années
j'ai j'ai écrit quelque chose sur la
crise d'octobre et j'ai eu un
commentaire pour dire que ressasser ces
différents mais bien sûr c'est un
chinois qui tisse à dire que c'est
différent tas d'histoires qui qu'ils les
acteurs 1970 ce prise d'otages la part
de gens qui sont en faveur de dépendance
du québec plus de monde la grc
qu'intervient l'armée qui est canadien
qui est envoyé au québec non une grande
histoire en jce oui je vais vous
proposer une autre page d'histoire
quand on parle de l'histoire que les
québécois se raconte
oui c'est lorsqu'il se raconte une
histoire en voici une belle deux
versions possibles
le discours c'était il ya cinquante ans
tout le monde opine c'est de tout le
monde sait de quoi je veux parler voilà
il ya dix villes montréal
bon ménage de limites
il s'agit du a prise d'un charles de
gaulle le général bien connu de la part
des alliés depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale comme étant un gars qui faisait
les choses un peu à sa façon sans être
un membre de l'équipe
les alliés un événement trop de
réputation en tout cas il ya notamment
real en il ya 50 ans 24 juillet voyage
en terre français sont deuxièmes le
premier tales est passé inaperçu mais
son deuxième en 1967 de québec est en
pleine effervescence
c'est un moment historique où il est
québécois revendique l'indépendance de
plus en plus et il fait ce discours je
vais vous présenter un extrait d'un
dossier spécial à faire cette semaine
par rci une minute presque deux minutes
la sphère du
minutes 30 mai on vous livre l'essentiel
ensuite à vous d'aller jouer dans les
pages du soir de radio canada une
formation je vais vous confier un secret
que vous ne resterez pas ce soir ici est
toujours de ma route je le trouvais dans
une atmosphère du même genre que celle
de la libération
si vous saviez qu'elle confiance
la france révélée après l'immense
épreuves portent maintenant faire vous
charles de gaulle voulait devenir foule
ce jour-là rétablir un lien brisé contre
le québec et sa mère patrie brizay deux
cents ans plus tôt quand la france avait
abandonné la nouvelle france futur
québec aux militaires anglais à la
recherche d'un symbole il a trouvé
peut-être une hyperbole quatre mots qui
allaient faire chavirer la foule et la
politique canadienne québec
[Applaudissements]
les bleus québec libre
ces quatre mots jetés du haut d'un
balcon par un politicien souvent
critiqué par ses alliés pour son côté
impétueux honte enthousiasme et une
grande partie du peuple québécois dans
la folle c'est le réveil captée par les
micros de radio canada
un étranger un gaulois venait de
reconnaître la résistance de ce petit
groupe d'irréductibles québécois est
temps que les politiciens du québec se
prononce cette question là maintenant ça
prenait un étranger pour le faire est ce
que vous en pensez quand il a crié vive
le québec libre
c'est un aspect psychologique pour la
foule non parce que à kayes et de la
suivre le québec la foule réagit
beaucoup alors le général a dit vive le
québec libre je pense qu'il pensait
vraiment que ce que disait ce point m
appartient à l'aise je pense que le mot
a été bien réfléchie de sap en france à
nous à londres à quelques avantages du
canada va comprendre que les québécois
actuel veulent vivre en français par la
france en moins de vingt quatre heures
il ya mille québec sur la carte bleue il
était le seul à voir la statue offert il
était le seul à oser briser les règles
pour le faire et il le fait c'est
extraordinaire le chef du parti
politique appelée rassemblement pour
l'indépendance nationale le fn pierre
bourgault se réjouissait de cet appui
inattendu à sa cause souverainiste
comment voulez vous qu'on ait des
aspirations comment vivre on a envie de
se voir quand on sait depuis deux ans
dans trompés et qu'on perd déjà être
profondément colonisés et c'est ça qui
nous a fait crier vive le général de
gaulle parce que lui pour la première
fois en deux ans dont il est venu là sur
notre terre veut dire en français trient
penser c'est le premier qui a gagné j'ai
voulu dire le combat par équipe et donc
sur la page de tam-tam canada ça promet
et bientôt d'autres interprétations
enfin pourquoi ceux d'autres et
plusieurs des protections et apparemment
il aurait improvisé la faire selon
certains selon certains historiens
toujours et puis selon d'autres ben non
ce programme aide avance depuis 2000
d'ailleurs 1960 il avait ça dans le
coeur l'avenir du québec
à vous de choisir votre version de
l'histoire et c'est un peu ce qu'on va
faire
quand on va célébrer cette saint jean
baptiste le 24
choisir sa version qu'on va cette cette
version de notre fierté francophone
bon moi je vous dis beaucoup de
francophones à l'extérieur du québec ont
leur propre fierté francophone je tiens
à le souligner parce qu'on a milli ons
francophones hors québec y en a qui sont
7 millions québec 7 millions d'onces que
le 1 million il pèse dans la balance et
on n'a pas ces gens-là célèbre tout cela
ça jean pax east 1 conçoit windsor en
ontario
n'importe où en saskatchewan en
louisiane
on sait si mes quatre jeunes et j'ai
appris quelque chose hier - en regardant
l'émission américaine comment ça
s'appelle cap à l'est avec halak soldats
canadiens à la louis louis louisiane
sagnet du roi louis hiel soleil
je savais même pas ce défaut ont fait
pas de lien au niveau désiré qu'on
connaît pas son histoire
oui mais mais il ya encore beaucoup de
gens qui parlent français à lucciana le
dans les rues par lequel j'ai en fait
dans certaines si on va dans les grandes
villes comme la nouvelle orléans il dira
mme un peu moins mais on entend encore
parler frugier télé ouais j'y suis allé
plusieurs fois j'adore ce malade ce coin
de francophones d'amérique là c'est
génial parce que c'est pas les actifs
qui qui sont loin le gadjo les dessins
les descendants de la d'acadiens autre
os oui bien sûr avec la déportation des
acadiens sont rendus en louisiane
beaucoup d'actifs est notre affaire
j'appelais cette semaine c'est que la
première saint jean baptiste est arrivée
par le bateau par la française 106 et
c'est en louisiane qu'on l'a célébré en
preniez un premier oui avant même le
québec jean baptiste puisque c'est le
jour de la saint jean
enfin selon les saints du calendrier la
célèbre précisément pour la célèbre le
québec en france c'est une fête
internationale voilà l'explication pour
soi le titre de lisser cette émission
qui était vive le québec libre dans ce
passage mais c'est vrai qu'on devrait
demander à nos auditeurs en français
pourquoi est-ce qu'on célèbre la saint
jean baptiste en france au fait
qu'est-ce qu'on s'élève précisément moi
je dis je serai jamais une petite
question pour vous ça nous mène à la
miss émission spéciale la semaine
prochaine toutes les émissions spéciales
en passant j'ai a précisé qu'il y avait
des deux points de notre émission la
semaine prochaine va porter sur le
canada sur le 150 ans du canada
alors voici combien de canadiens quel
pourcentage de canadiens qui aimerait
bien qu'on se débarrasse de la couronne
britannique de son nos épaules parce que
c'est que l'angleterre est en club
la reine d'angleterre est encore là chef
de l'état a dit oui même si on a
rapatrié notre constitution et en 1981
oui probablement
je joue je vais vous écoutez là dessus
on vérifiera aps la semaine prochaine
pas la semaine prochaine mais vous me le
dire et ensuite grâce à toute cette
science que vous nous laisser comme ça
entre les mains on va faire une bonne
émission je vous assure
elle vous la même réponse à cette
question
ce pourcentage des canadiens qui pensent
que ça prouverait la tenue d'un
référendum portant sur l'indépendance du
canada face à la monarchie 33% 33% enfin
tour de tambouille 80 80 % pour moi
c'est comme ça 55
un peu comme un vote référendaire bonne
réponse pas moins de 44%
c'est ce que j'allais j'étais pas trop
juste que vous alliez dire ça comme ça
elle a des raisons à 55 parce que 58 %
des québécois sont plus nombreux et plus
en faveur de sa que les canadiens c'est
je suis surprise de voir qu'il ya encore
tant de canadiens qui qui s'attachent là
bas moi je m'y attache parce que si elle
était plus le dirai plus j'aurai plus
d'argent dans les poches
et surtout n'oubliez dedans comme j'ai
toujours fait qu'est ce qu'on ferait
avec ça on a commencé à changer certains
billets de banque et à mettre des hommes
et des femmes de grande canadienne de
grands canadiens sur nos gants corps
mutilés c'est beaucoup le vin le vin
coin de 20 $ ou la reine trône sédiments
36 heures sans trop nous les vrais les
gens plus juteuse licence
moi je n'ai que des dollars dans les
poches ça existe pas les deux de la
mairie
je me rappelle pamela la semaine passée
on avait dit tout les anniversaires qui
en avait cette année là pour cent
cinquantième le 375e
ainsi de suite puis conduit sans à
l'ouest de l'île je vais 5,25 en deux je
me rappelle pas quelles villes de
l'ouest du délai les montréalais à 55
ans je ne sais pas si c'était quelqu'un
ou quelque chose comme ça mais où nos
routes ralentissant françois nadeau du
spa toutes les villes qui célèbre cette
année son 25e anniversaire de naissance
voilà
écoutez merci beaucoup pour cette
animation fait cette émission animée qui
était très agréable on vous enverra plus
vous partez en vacances au niveau oui
oui je reviens après le 14 juillet a
tout de suite après défaite des français
voilà tout et puis oui où vous allez
peut-être revenir dans trois semaines
c'est votre prochaine fenêtre pour votre
prochaine sortie très bien et puis marie
claude
puis il ya ma taurine noté ya qui nous
dit bon après midi
alors bon après midi